so are we all ready to get started so
our first speaker is Jess Lee she's the
CEO and co-founder Polyvore which is a
global community that helps people
discover and shop for things they love
in fashion beauty and home decor
Justus here to talk about how Polyvore
has grown to a community of 20 million
monthly users by building a very
delighted community of building a
community of delighted users so please
let's give a warm welcome to Jess Lee
hi everyone who here is starting their
own company or has their own company or
is interested all right great
welcome to the long road it's really
really rewarding and really really hard
one of the hardest things you're gonna
have to do is figure out how to grow
users so Polyvore is a community site so
I wanted to talk a little bit today
about community hacks how to grow a
community so just before I get started
real quick I'm Jess and the CEO and
co-founder of Polyvore my story is a
little bit unusual because I started as
the product manager actually I started
as a user of Polyvore who was really in
love with the product and I wrote a note
to the co-founders with some suggestions
on how to make the product better then
they hired me and after a couple of
years we were all working together they
said you know what we we think of you as
a co-founder I'm just gonna start
calling you an honorary co-founder and
then eventually I became CEO so it's a
pretty unusual journey you might say I'm
a hustler
and prior to that I was a product
manager at Google Maps and then I
studied computer science before that I
loved manga drawing and bacon I was at
Comic Con last week and if you want to
follow me on Twitter I'm just Jessica or
you can check out my blog at Jesse o
cocom so for those of you who don't know
Polyvore we're a new way to discover and
shop for things that you love in fashion
home decor and beauty so what our users
do is they mix and match their favorite
products real products into collages
that we call sets and million what about
20 million people come to polymorph to
browse and shop those looks we have
about 20 million visitors per month
we're the second largest driver of
social commerce traffic
the web so first is Facebook then
Polyvore then Pinterest and then Twitter
obviously we're much smaller in terms of
user base and all those guys but we
drive really high quality traffic that
actually converts to sale and we have a
global community of users who create
about 4 million pieces of content per
month that's 4 million of these
beautiful collages so that's a lot of
content a very active user community so
the topic for today is a little bit
about growth hacking but not the usual
type of growth hacking that most people
talk about the viral loops the email
retention programs but really about what
we believe is that the best way to grow
is actually to cultivate a really
delighted community of users so why this
matters so much is because when you have
people who are really delighted who love
your product are your advocates what
happens is they can't help but tell
their friends about it and what happens
is you get this natural word-of-mouth so
it's very viral and that leads to viral
growth I want to give a couple of
examples of how this has helped Polyvore
traffic growth so so much of our traffic
in the early days came from blogs and
what would happen is someone would use
Polyvore and find the experience
interesting and unique and hadn't seen
it before so then they'd write a blog
post like hey check out this site and
that in turn would drive all of their
readers and their followers back to
Polyvore nowadays that's happening on
Twitter or Facebook or Pinterest or
tumblr but this has been part of it it's
a huge part of our traffic growth over
the years so that's one way that delight
is really led to growth the other
interesting thing is it's also led to
fundraising growth or funding so one of
our investors actually called me while
we were in the middle of raising our
Series C and he said hey I'd like to
invest and I was like great would you
like to do you know do you want me to
come over to your office and do you know
the pitch show you the numbers he said
no I don't need I don't need to hear it
I I'm in and I was like oh that's that's
great
why you know and he said well I heard
about you three times in a very short
period of time and that's why I'm in and
so the three examples were his assistant
uses Polyvore and told him about it his
best friend who happens to be the CEO of
a major fashion brand mentioned it to
him at dinner in Paris
and then the third was at his one of his
old colleagues who is in an exec at an
investment bank mentioned it to him at a
conference in Vegas so three sort of
mentions all over the world from people
he knew he picked up the phone and
called so that delight where you have
someone just dropping your name in a
positive way can really it can really
lead to in this case million dollars
worth of funding so it's really really
important so I'm just gonna talk through
some of the community hacks they fall
under three principles the first their
live learn and love and I'll go through
each of them and then talk a little bit
about what we do so live is that what
this really means is that community
starts from within so before you start
thinking about how to go externally and
do growth hacking and get your community
first you have to really believe in the
power of your user community you have to
truly care about it your because if you
don't it'll end up showing so your
social media manager if they don't
really love and respect your user
community then they might tweet
something and use it the wrong tone of
voice if your engineers don't really
care about the users and respect them
they might build a feature that
disrespects their privacy so it's really
really important that you start first
internally inside your company and
figure out how to make sure that
everybody cares so the ways that we do
this first you have to make it part of
your culture so Polly wears three core
values delight the user do a few things
well and make an impact the first one is
basically about the user we want to
delight the user so that's baked into
the core values the second is that we
actually make everyone at Polyvore go
through a orientation where they sit
down with the community team the
community walks them through and talks
of how much we love the community and
how much you know the profiles
interesting members so that's a picture
of our orientation so you have to really
start baking it into your culture very
early on then a little nother thing to
make sure the communities all surrounds
your team is we decorate the office with
community memorabilia love letters that
they send us we post them on the wall we
decorate the office with the beautiful
collages the sets that our community
makes when we get flowers or nice notes
handwritten notes from our community we
pass them around desk to desk in the
office so everyone can read the
the read the love letter we do a weekly
email update so the community team
actually writes up things like what you
should know the top community requests a
love letter each week and the spotlight
on a members who get a sense of like who
are these people who's behind you know
the the user ID number that the
engineers see we also at some point once
your team is a little bit larger I would
definitely recommend hiring a community
team I think our community manager was
the sixth higher at Polyvore so that's
actually fairly early on but we wanted
someone dedicated to this the community
team does a combination of customer
support as well as top member outreach a
lot of companies only do the first part
the customer support and they forget
about how do you like make sure you have
a strong relationship with your top
members who are advocates so the second
principle is learned you want to learn a
lot from your community it's so valuable
to have those users and to get their
input back into your product is really
important you have to listen to them you
have to incorporate their feedback into
your product and then you have to let
them know that you incorporated their
feet feedback into the product so one
thing we do is we try to get feedback
quite early we might do a beta test with
a select group of members where they get
access to a feature early or we might do
something even earlier than that where
we'll build a prototype for apps we
really like this this tool called Flint
Oh your designers can make mocks and
wire them up and you can basically click
have a click through prototype that
looks fairly polished this is Jason one
of our product managers holding
Starbucks cards so you can give little
you know little prizes little gifts to
people to help out thanks for helping
out but what we do is we we get this
feedback early and then incorporate it
into the development process recently I
think we had a whole bunch of our
engineers and our product manager and
our our designers go gorilla style into
Stanford mall and just ask people to
look at things and we got a lot of
really good feedback that was
incorporated directly into the product
in the next revision then once you're
ready and you have your feature all
designed it's really really important
how you roll it out so you have to write
a really good launch announcement
do this on our blog generally and this
is an example and I think the most
important thing is to explain why you've
done something most companies just say
here is what we've built love it
you should really see this is why you
should love it here's what we did
especially in particular if you're
making large changes it's gonna be the
case where you you discover something
confusing about your interface you
discover that you want to change
something and people tend to have change
of version so how many of you remember
when the Facebook newsfeed first rolled
out or the wall everybody hated it right
they were like petition saying I hate
this and now it's just such a normal
part of Facebook like you can't even
imagine what what it was like when there
wasn't a wall or a newsfeed but everyone
hated it in the beginning and that's
because of change aversion so in
anticipation of that especially once
your products a little bit more
established and you have those top
members it's really important how you
announce the features so this is a post
that is from earlier this week we
recently redesigned our iPhone app so we
changed from a horizontal scrolling
model swipe left to right to a
up-and-down scrolling model and you know
it we think it's a better design we
tested it we found that the stats were
better but we knew that the community
might be upset that we changed it so we
wanted to really explain why so this is
the post that we wrote we said the
reason we've done this is to make it
more fun and easy to find and browse
what you love we got feedback that it
was confusing and that's why we've
changed it changed it and we mentioned
that we did actually beta test it with
people and their feedback was positive
so those little little inclusions of
information make a big difference to
your community then what we also do is
we listen carefully to the feedback we
actually create a Google Doc and we
collect all that all the feedback so our
social media manager will you know put
tweets that she's received into this doc
will collect all the comments off of our
blog people will sometimes comment on
sets that our team has made with
feedback and put that all together and
then we tally up the top requests and
then it gives us you know a little bit
of quantitative data and qualitative
comments from our users telling us what
they like or don't like so this is an
example of the feedback that we got from
the beta test of that visual design
change that I showed you in the previous
slide and it was overall quite positive
but you can see that they're a bunch of
negative comments and we went and tried
to address as many of those as possible
while you know you can't respond to
every little community thing you can't
you can't do exactly what your users
tell you to do but it was good to see
the feedback to validate or invalidate
some of our hypotheses then once you've
figured out what you're going to do what
you're going to change it's really
important to respond back to the
community with updates so this is from a
while back we we changed our messaging
system inside of the Paulo in side of
Polyvore and we we got some complaints
about the new interactions and then we
figured out how we should fix these
specific things and you can see there
are three updates update one two three
or we actually wrote back to commute
saying hey thanks for the feedback we're
gonna working on fixing some of this
stuff then hey we've made some changes
let us know you think and then last
seatt we're working on more changes and
that dialogue really shows your
community that it's it's a two-way
conversation it makes you sound human it
shows that you're listening and it makes
a really big difference also when there
are problems you need to address them
head-on don't try to bury them so this
is a from this is from I think yesterday
there was a user who wrote in to
complain about our Android app and it's
because our Android app asks for a bunch
of permissions and she's like why do i
why you need all these permissions and
our social media managers wrote back and
said hey you know we're sorry you know
it does seem confusing and unnecessary
but the reason for it is Google has
actually grouped some of this stuff
under these terms and we need into these
buckets and we need some of the details
in there and hey we're not gonna prank
call you don't worry and I thought this
is a really nice way to handle it with a
sort of fun human tone like we're having
a conversation with a real person
sometimes you'll screw things up you'll
launch it was one time we launched all
of our a/b test experiments all at the
same time everything was turned on and
was such a confusing because we
immediately turned it off but people
people were really upset they're like
why did you change everything all of a
sudden so or when there are outages when
the site goes down for a little bit you
know we just say sorry we're really
really sorry here's what we know about
when it's gonna be fixed everyone's
working really hard on it we worked
through
the night those little bits of
communication make a big difference and
also when great things happen to you
like we want a webby award this year we
make sure to go back and tell the
community about it and thank them
because without them we would really be
nothing the last principle is love you
should really make sure you can you
notice how much you care by how much you
love and appreciate them so one easy
thing to do as especially as you're
starting out when you don't have a lot
of budget to you know to share and give
to your users what you can do is just
interview your top members spotlight
them highlight them in your social media
tweeted them on your on Twitter what we
do is we interview our members and we'll
ask them you know what's trending in
your neighborhood in terms of fashion
tell us a little bit about you and why
you use the product and will write
interviews make content about them and
then feature them on across our homepage
in the app in our social media and our
Facebook page then maybe once you have a
little bit more budget to work with
because you're starting to you know you
maybe you got funding maybe you do it
out of your own pocket cuz you care
maybe you can partner with advertisers
to do something one thing that we've
done is send gifts
small gifts that are personalized and
then most importantly handwritten
thank-you notes I can't tell you how
many times we've you know we've done a
meet-up and we've given them gifts and
then there's a little note and they're
you know there's all these presents and
the thing they're most excited about is
that we took the time to write a
handwritten note you people just don't
write letters anymore or notes anymore
so it's I think it is still something
that's kind of special and we will
sometimes pass them around the office
and have lots of people sign them and
it's just an easy thing to do so why not
do it it does make a big difference to
people and then our community managers
sometimes go out of the way to do
personalized gifts so this one time that
picture on the left is some of our users
having received this box where they open
it and they find an item that they've
used in their Polyvore sets before that
our commune managers have dug through
their sets and they then they discover
that my gift is different from yours and
I use this in four sets and it was they
were so happy there were people crying
it's just it's just that little bit of
extra when you go the extra mile that
people will remember that
and once we got even we got a little bit
more funding we're able to do this we
wanted to help the community actually
achieve their career goals and their
dreams in their aspiration so we asked
them hey who in the community is
actually interested in a job in the
fashion industry what are your
aspirations what do you want to do so we
put out we did like a survey we got all
this feedback and then from there we
were able to figure out how to use our
connections as a company and our
personal network to make some of that
happen so Samara
on the Left we were able to set her up
with an internship at Cynthia Rowley a
fashion designer in the middle we sent a
bunch of people to fashion shows to do
community to be our community
correspondents so we sometimes get
tickets to shows to cover them but we
you know we're here we're mostly
engineers so we sent our community
members to the shows and have them
create content about them the third
example is that's Olivia Lopez she's an
amazing blogger and Polyvore user and we
got we partnered her with a designer to
create her own design collaboration for
they design that shoe that she's wearing
they called it the Olivia boot and it
was on sale and it sold out so that was
something that she got to do so we
definitely try to make sure that our
community is really really happy so
those are the three principles live
community starts from within learn learn
from the community feedback that you get
and incorporate into your product and
love show them how much you love and
appreciate them and when you do these
things right you will see growth and you
will see these kinds of comments from
your commute so I'm just gonna read this
this is from Heather she's been a member
of Paul on Polyvore for probably six
years and she said as long as I've been
a member of Polly board the team has
always been attentive and kept the
community their number one priority I
always assumed that as Polly board grew
the genuine concern for user
satisfaction would take a backseat to
company goals fortunately I was wrong
I'm continually amazed at how much of a
family atmosphere Polly Ward's able to
create all over the world I'm so
thankful to be part of this community
and I sing praises for Polyvore every
chance I get
so I do really when I look back on the
history of polymer and how we've gotten
to this point with the 20 million users
I do really feel that this and the way
that our community management team
treats our community has been a big part
of our success so I just wanted to share
those growth hacking tips
you guys thank you
I'll actually start with a question yes
hi big fan of your work we went to
college together crashing in her house
right Thank You Jess you've done a great
job in cultivating the Maven community
you know getting your top users to get
together meet in person you know get
them excited about Polyvore show how
much that you guys love them back and I
was wondering you know what are your
thoughts in terms of extending that
relationship a bit further in terms of
you know when you guys have a huge
release you know leveraging those
bloggers to talk about it or seeping it
with them first is that something that
you guys actively pursue or how do you
view that relationship yeah so we we
definitely think about that when we have
a bigger release what we like to do is
have a beta test group where they get
early access we you know you're invited
to a special sneak peak of this new
feature this new app that we're working
on we'd love your feedback it's still a
work in progress you know your your
feedback means a lot to us and will help
us make the product better
so you phrase it that way so that they
don't get pissed when they see all the
bugs because early right and then you
actually do incorporate their feedback
and make sure that group in particular
you respond to their emails and say hey
thanks for that or oh sorry that was a
bug so then they feel like part of this
you know they feel like they're really
contributing because they really are and
then when the feature is ready to go you
can email them again and let them know
that to tell their friends as well as
what we've also seen happen is because
of change aversion sometimes the rest of
the community who hasn't seen it before
will be like oh I hate this like why did
you change this I liked it the way it
was before and then those people who
were in the beta test sometimes they
come out of the woodwork and be and
comment back for you on your behalf and
say hey I thought it sucked at first too
but then I played for it for played with
it for a week and now I love it and that
is much much more powerful than you
saying hey just wait a week and you'll
love it too it's better when the
community comes out and says that for
you yeah so I think that's a big part of
our release strategy thank you first
question
hi I'm Susan I am the head of community
for a community oriented health care
social media company and we have a same
sort of situation a really strong
community of really big fans and then a
couple of outliers that are still part
of our community better maybe a little
bit higher maintenance and I was
wondering if you have some insight into
how you've trained your team to handle
those kinds of folks within the
community and sort of when to draw the
line on engagement and when to pull back
and how you handle just those people
that need a little bit of extra
attention and maybe aren't necessarily
100% negative but are really challenging
in their own way I think we've been
lucky to have not a lot of people who
are super challenging like we do have
occasional incidents where someone's
really angry about something and I think
we we sometimes send them flowers after
we resolve the issue even then even with
those challenging people I still think
it's important to go that extra mile and
then you do have to use your your your
best judgment so I think we just tried
to find a team that genuinely cared and
just said hey treat them like you would
treat a real just a real human right and
then they've written internal guidelines
for themselves on how to do that and
it's fairly self-regulating